das x 58 x noch einst familie hatte die
tat ich nur angst von lehrer heute was
geht ab und bekommen bei einem neuen
video hier mal wieder auf einem kanal
und so ja auf jeden fall können wir
diese woche mal die wunderschöne idee
und zwar ja ich war ja mal in der
fünften klasse jetzt bin ich in der
zehnten klasse und da gibt es ja so
kleine unterschiede was das verhalten
angeht deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
kommt machte darüber meinen video also
heute geht es einfach um schule früher
vs schule heute oder schule früher und
schule heute ja einfach so mal so ein
bisschen die unterschiede ich meine
single schule früher 40 jahre an die
schulzeit sondern einfach vor fünf
jahren als ich in der fünften klasse war
und ja wie es jetzt ausschaut so einfach
an ich wünsche euch viel spaß und ja vor
drei tagen
wo war das wieder ein aufregender
schultag
was hat mir noch mal in deutsch abschlag
ist doch mal schnell meinem
hausaufgabenheft nach ich schreib mir
glücklicherweise immer meine ganzen
hausaufgaben auf seite 22 08
danach an an den speck
soll ich halt mal die hausaufgaben
machen
es war das überhaupt dicker weißer
zufälligen was wir in englisch aufatmen
also wie das mache man das noch gerät
line 8 herr auch wieder recht was schon
halb sieben scheiße ich will heute erst
auf dem schulhof sein sagt er schon fünf
vor acht
egal ob erinnert kann ja noch weiter
schlafen
ach du heiliger bimbam jetzt hätte ich
ja fast bei neues handy mit in die
schule genommen
es gibt ja nicht umsonst die handyverbot
regel nachher gibt es da noch ärger vom
lehrer was ist eigentlich los mit den
lehrern heutzutage ja gar nichts mehr
du raus online das tut mir doch so laut
ich passe jetzt wirklich auf der lehre
und ich wirklich ganz viel für die
nächste motto heute überhaupt
beschlossen mich hier im unterricht raus
lehrer hat gesprochen verpiss dich
das heißt ich kann jetzt gehen endlich
soweit und dann sind wir hier um leider
schon wieder am ende dieses videos ich
hoffe natürlich es hat euch wie mal
gefallen was sie aber auf jeden fall
noch sagen muss bitte nehmen das jetzt
nicht ganz so ernst ich habe in dem
einen oder anderen fall natürlich auch
ein bisschen übertrieben viel vielleicht
gemerkt habt wenn ihr mir dennoch recht
gibt dann gebt doch einfach mal doch
nach oben wenn es generell feiern
einfach daumen nach oben instagram und
co alles und in der video beschreibung
abonnieren nicht vergessen und hier
unten links geht es jetzt weiter mit
meinem letzten video da habe ich so
meine apps auf dem handy vorgestellt und
hier unten rechts mit dinge die jeder
schüler kennt damit ein kumpel schon
etwas länger her check 2 ist aus wir
sehen uns nächstes wochen eine schönes
wochenende noch nicht schön sonntag noch
rein und die kamera die vergleich und
runter hier